[Musique]
m
les casques sont un symbole de maidan je
pensais que c'était de l'histoire
ancienne mais aujourd'hui c'est redevenu
d'actualité
je continuerai aussi longtemps qu'il le
faudra c'est ma contribution pour
l'ukraine pour mon pays pour les gens
que je connais là bas je ne sais rien
faire d'autre que peindre
en 2014 le soulèvement populaire de
maidan marque un tournant pour tatiana
chez prasow va
il provoque un changement de régime à
kiev mais aussi un bouillonnement
artistique dont elle est une figure de
proue en ukraine
[Musique]
aujourd'hui réfugié en france elle
poursuit son engagement
[Musique]
poutine est un être assez primitive
selon moi c'est le mal incarné aucun de
ces plans n'a fonctionné et ça le rend
fou de rage et tout ça a commencé avec
maidan comment peut-on accorder un titre
honorifique aux soldats qui ont commis
des tueries abuja
comme cette peintre syrienne qui
partagent la même pièce tatiana est
accueillie en résidence par l'atelier
des artistes en exil une association
parisienne qui relève un défi ambitieux
réunir ici des réfugiés ukrainiens et
russes qui dénonce la guerre d'une même
voix et les nalanda et et galeriste à
saint-pétersbourg
pour moi c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
important dans le contexte actuel
d'avoir cet îlot où la violence n'a pas
sa place nous venons tous ici pour
chercher de l'aide
j'ai de nombreux amis peintres qui ont
manifesté contre la guerre et qui ont
été obligés de quitter le pays
ceux qui sont restés en russie seront
arrêtés et réprimer
panne et c'est en fait
depuis la mi mars de ligne téléphonique
dédiée permettent à l'association de
traiter les demandes incessantes
nadejda et russes et les cja ukrainienne
les artistes qui arrivent ici bien se
répondent dans l'état psychologique
compliqué fragile parce que d'abord
c'est difficile
se retrouver au milieu de la guerre tu
arrives dans une pays où tu parle pas
français tueur pas la langue
il ya beaucoup de demandes des artistes
craignent un bien sûr il ya aussi
beaucoup de demandes et artistes et
russe ce qui est moins évident ce sont
tous ces gens qui sont menacés en russie
par leur position en politique et donc
qu'ils cherchent les possibilités de
sortir du pays pour les responsables de
l'atelier cette cohabitation s'est
imposé comme une évidence
il y avait une forme d'ambivalence chez
certains à l'égard des russes dissidents
en disant qu'il faut soutenir les rues
sombres à nous on pense qu'il faut
fermement soutenir tous les russes qui
s'opposent à la politique de poutine et
nous avons des dizaines voire des
centaines de demandes d'artistes russes
pour obtenir des visas et venir en
france et quitter ce pays où ils ne
peuvent plus vivre
vadim est l'un de ces russes pour qu'ils
l'exil est devenue la seule solution
envisageable
je suis parti de russie quand la guerre
a commencé c'est la principale raison
c'est difficile de faire comme si rien
ne s'était passé
quand votre pays est traité comme un
agresseur et c'est ce qu'il est cela
vous affecte de manière très
destructrice
ce vidéaste s'est remis au travail dès
son arrivée il est de nidal dans la mer
et ukrainiennes à mettre en images son
ballet contemporain
je n'accuse pas le peuple russe j'accuse
le régime russe ce n'est pas la même
chose je vois vadim comme une personne
c'est tout
j'ai choisi de dessiner au crayon comme
mes amies de kiev qui se sont souvent
retrouvés dans des abris avec ce qu'ils
avaient sous la main
ils n'avaient souvent qu'une seule
couleur ou qu'un crayon
lorsque nous rencontrons cristina elle
arrive à peine d'ukraine
a été évacués de la maternité de
marioupol dont
elle est enceinte est encore vivante
même si elle est gravement blessé
et pour moi c'est un symbole de notre
pays
nous remettrons malgré nos blessures
c'est très reconnaissante pour l'atelier
pour avoir cette possibilité
après les massacres après cette atrocité
de pouvoir parler aux ukrainiens et de
se regarder dans les yeux c'est très
important
quelques semaines plus tard
l'association organise une exposition
dénonçant la guerre en ukraine
l'occasion pour tatiana et d'autres
artistes ukrainiens et russes de montrer
leur travail au public est
l'aboutissement d'un projet qui a généré
quelques résistances
des fois c'est pas évident pour les
ukrainiens et certains artistes
manifestent des réticences
je pense que ça va prendre du temps et
qu'il faut laisser aux personnes le
temps aimé que quand même ce qui est
plus important c'est que l'art arrive à
transcender et qu'on dépasse cette
animosité
et cette haine
l'atelier des artistes en exil ne compte
pas en rester à ce coup d'essai une
nouvelle exposition plus importante est
prévue dans le courant de l'année